we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
all right i'll tell you good to be here
folks you're all right you're all right
all right ready and go well that was
good that was good all right yeah keep
it hey all right we'll keep it in hey
we're back baby we might be drunk
episode i don't know 30 something
probably who the hell can keep track
we're drunk
like salaccus's age
1942 good producer really seems to care
yeah
all right well look we're back we're
better than ever
we're being healthy this week look at
this we got wheatgrass shots we got
smoothies we might be gay is this mine
yeah no wait i got the the red recovery
or whatever which
i wanted the green one yeah flip it
flip it the old um what is it
princess bride oh good save that could
have been ugly
that was a wallace shawn
my dinner with andre one of one of the
greatest snoozers of all yeah i used to
love that [ __ ] movie
oh i got crap for
told you i told you that and like i told
my mom and like you both loved it i
loved it i was a film student
pretentious [ __ ] and i told everybody i
loved it but it is i couldn't watch it
again let's do it let's do a wheatgrass
shot hell yeah
we gotta cleanse the system here what's
your toast to ooh
that's a good question i mean i love the
weather in new york it's autumn
can't beat it 70 degrees outside and the
sun is shining you know what's funny
this is gonna be harder to take than
tequila oh it smells like crap this is
hell we shoot alcohol it's funny i see i
see people complain when they take a
whiskey shot and i'm like [ __ ] yeah i
don't want to see my face after i take
this wheatgrass right yeah this is
there's gonna be shooting in another
direction yeah oh yeah
i'd rather drink jizz
that's not bad actually
i'm surprised at the end smells worse
than it is that's true it's kind of like
lawn trimmings
ah man
that was tough
now does that actually help is that it
really doing anything nobody knows what
do we know yeah
i don't know if it helps you see these
la people taking these every day and i'm
like what do you know
is that anything your state's on fire
how do you know all homeless states on
fire the whole thing
that the la homeless scene is rough too
because it's like a lot you can tell a
lot they're good-looking homeless people
so you could tell a lot of them had
bigger dreams oh that's true hobo looks
like hugh jackman you're like [ __ ]
you should have been a contender right
yeah cause it used to be oh that's a
good looking actor i mean a good looking
waiter he's probably an actor now it's a
good looking hobo
this is pretty good
i think we're gonna feel good after this
i hope so this is like the opposite of a
cocktail it's like
it's not that good going down but i
think the other end yeah we're good
right now the beard jew is somewhere in
new york going
i feel a weird pain in my chest
i feel like we're cheating on him with
this [ __ ]
well yeah man i'm i'm hurting still but
i'm getting there the neck the back the
neck's killing me but i'm getting there
man what are you going to be like at 80.
it ain't going to be pretty i'm going to
be pushing you around on a wheelchair
i'm going to be i'm going to be one of
those guys who's like bent in half you
ever see those
the city literally broke them yeah like
this yes they're like a [ __ ] right
angle
there you go yeah that's got to start
somewhere like have you seen bernie
sanders posture oh
man it's all shoulders it's just he's
like a scarecrow
yeah
it's just like you just see all that
anxiety he has you know he's like an
anxious guy yeah you know it's like all
here all up there he's got a hump that
guy i mean that's just years of activism
just weighing on him like oh civil
rights and anti-semitism and uh you know
rich people
the hunchback of burlington starting
burning
yeah no you look at him he's not
oh yeah oh man it's just no neck andy's
skin has turned pink he looks like a
baby gerbil oh yeah there's some
benjamin button vibes going on what
about my ass yeah he does he's got a
real bridge troll thing cooking there
he's like it's one of the he's the
eighth dwarf jewie he scares you with
com he scares you with complaints
these allergies are killing me oh my god
a future to believe in what what is he
doing now i always wonder like yang
what's yang up to all these guys oh he's
still a senator oh is he yeah oh all
right that's something yeah he's still
he's still around what do they mean he
just had a heart attack what they make a
few hundred k probably but he's also
rich from books oh yeah that was the
whole thing that he has extra
that he has like a summer home and
you're like he's 80. like right
that's true he needs once you're over 75
just let him have it yeah that's true
you know what they say after 75k a year
you don't get happier you ever heard
that i believe it yeah i believe it too
well look at rodney dangerfield man
still miserable he was a miserable guy i
don't think i don't think money and fame
bring you happiness no because then you
there's always something if that's what
you're chasing
it's not something that that
satisfies you yeah they say never buy
your dream car because then you have
nothing to shoot for
it's just a metaphor even though i
bought mine
suck it
people i can't drive so oh yeah that
works for me so you'll be really
miserable
or i'll be really happy or happy or
happy yeah it's all a choice i just need
a dream car and to continue to never be
able to drive and i'll stay happy there
you go yeah there you go i'll give you a
ride
yeah that's true yeah they you got to
find your own happiness you got to do it
yourself it's all up here folks yeah
that's what they say that's what they
say man yeah what uh what's what's in
your smoothie here what are you what are
you sipping on here oh i got like these
i got some beets
that's brain food they say yes beets and
peppermint supposed to be good for the
brain peppermint yeah
i didn't know that yeah beets by dre
carrot i think some radish and maybe uh
celery
i don't know i feel like celery is good
for you i think it is it's the only food
where you eat it and you burn calories
because it's so has so little food like
fat or or calories that actually chewing
it burns more than it is so why are we
eating it
uh tastes good
nope
nutrients you throw some peanut butter
on there it's pretty good ants on a log
yeah a little raisin action oh yeah
peanut butter is versatile oh it's my
favorite you can put it anywhere i get
the thing from uh amazon it's like this
big it's like a drum really oh yeah
cause i don't want to keep buying it i
keep buying it every week i'm a junkie
that's your vice peanut butter you've
never gotten the almond butter crazed i
tried it it doesn't hit the spot crunchy
or creamy
creamy what i know i get this every time
get this
who do you crunch ah you guys are a
bunch of bernie bros with your crunch
crunch what would you rather have
who doesn't want crunch why would i want
more obstacles in my life i want to just
slurp it in
is this i don't need to be olympics
i don't need to be chewing all day
all day
what about these uh natural peanut
butters what a nightmare that is where
you got to mix the oil in like wow
at work that's worked i'll give you
that's work what am i amish i'm [ __ ]
shaking it i'm churning butter here
exactly i'm mixing things every day get
out of town i just want to scoop it i
can't believe you're creamy over my see
my girlfriend got creamy the other day
yeah and i was like i didn't say
anything but i was kind of like what the
hell and i was like and then one day i
just i brought up i was like are you a
creamy person
and she and she goes no i'm crunchy it's
just i only had creamy and i was like
interesting i'm creamy over nothing okay
but i'm crunchy if i've got the option
i think i'm prison uh creamy
oh yeah i got you and i got you the only
thing there i'll take it but i prefer
the term smooth if you call it creamy it
sounds a little
sexual yeah crunchy versus smooth sexual
who would you rather hang out with a guy
who's crunchy or a guy who's smooth did
the sex act ruin the boston cream pie
what is a boston cream pie it's like a
what it was look look it up it's like a
it's like a cream pie i know the cream
pie i don't know the boston cream pie
that's where you get
oh like the boston cream doughnut you
ever do that oh that's a good doughnut
great doughnut there's a boston cream
but wait what's the sex act it's gotta
be the cream pie is just you come inside
someone their ass and then it comes out
i believe but what makes it a boston
yeah because that's just a great father
[Laughter]
cleveland steamer it doesn't come from
cleveland i know but a steamer isn't an
act a cream pie
is i know but it's got cleveland but
there's no steamer alone a cream pie can
be alone is what i'm saying
i think the boston cream pies when you
cream inside a woman and then uh go
chase your dreams like will hunting
it's not your fault
i gotta see about an ass
what is the uh i went along i went
longer for that joke than he went to go
find that girl
[Laughter]
great role by the way by robin by robin
williams oh yeah killed it as the
serious uh psychiatrist yeah i just saw
matt damon in interviews say that
their whole idea was like i think they
heard reservoir dogs tarantino got 500k
of funding once they got harvey keitel
attached so that
when he and ben affleck were writing it
they were like we just need to get
one actor attached and we can get this
made so they
they cast such a wide net with that
character like it could have been a
woman we voted so like if meryl streep
was interested it could work we could
have been a black guy we could have had
that like southie tension oh yeah
like if denzel was interested and then
they got you know robin williams wow
killed it won the oscar right won the
oscar
i believe he did i think he did i think
i'm only one for writing i don't know if
he won for that i think he won i think
he won look it up that year i think it
was 97. they were so that was a hot year
hot year well i think uh was that uh la
conf
i think that might have been the next
year
but um or maybe
oh
yes you're right titanic boogie nights
wow
as good as the guests
that was a fun year movies really fell
off a cliff they really did in the 90s
man they were on a tears like saving
private ryan forrest gump pulp fiction
and he got that role he said he got that
role because robin williams introduced
him to spielberg
wait who uh huh oh oh oh
matt damon a spielberg so he was like uh
oh he like he had gained weight i guess
because he was really skinny for some
movie done and he's like oh i saw you in
that i really liked you but like and so
the guy needs to be heavier and then you
met him and he was like oh he's heavier
wow
i think it was courage under five yes
that's what it was you're good that's
what put him on the map because he got
really thin they were right here about
1997 best supporting actor
good will hunting hell yeah this is good
dude
i never do this i don't like it you did
green and green yeah the green shot and
the green drink bernie
it's all green green new deal what did
you get you got the orange pizzazz
it's got like a recovery yeah it's like
a share it yeah a lot of ginger a lot of
ginger
ginger you don't like it it just burns i
don't know why it's good is that good i
mean i think so depends what a name was
all right
was it worth it ah there it was
there's a clip
yeah i was i was a smoothie every other
day guy for a while
they're so expensive in new york they're
like 20 bucks now yeah roy wood's got
that great bit about uh
peach tranquility he goes the
tranquility's like five dollars just
give me the peach
man i like it you did a little rodney on
that
page i just thought you guys want to
hear my prior i'll tell you the cops ah
boy roy wood it's one of the best comics
in the country and one of the best
people great guy so i'm watching um only
murders in the building the show with
steve martin and martin short
and roy wood's in it he's got a cameo in
it and he's got a cameo with martin
short and steve martin so i text him
like what the hell and he's like he's
like oh i got stories for you like spent
the whole day with them said they
couldn't have been cooler we got to get
them on here we got to get them on here
does he live in new york he does right
he's on the daily show
you never know anymore he's got kids and
the pandemic i don't know yeah i feel
like a lot of comics now they're just on
the road yes exactly the road is because
you're tired during the week if you're
on the road every week like we are yeah
why does your shirt say gay dracula no
somebody sent this to me i don't know
what it means it might be a band it
might be a
a sex act i don't know do you feel weird
walking around the street in a shirt
that says gay on it no no cause i'm like
this is your problem you guys figure it
out because i'm getting a lot of like
what the hell is that and then they feel
out like not in the know
so i'm loving it all right
i don't know can we can we google it
look it up again nothing here all right
even better
it's like that bar with no sign
oh there's a sign
[Laughter]
okay dracula there you go you're lucky
we're in uh herald square not uh chelsea
you would have been chasing this
building right here
i'll take it oh yeah
loving this smoothie man this is good
man i'm into it salaki's really [ __ ]
up with all that ginger yep nothing
worse than an irishman
ginger if you rearrange it what do you
get
oh boy all right it's not my joke that's
not
it's not a joke
that [ __ ] just bad well it's somebody
has that joke i can't i think it's byron
bowers oh okay yeah oh yeah okay
context is big with that sure sure sure
he's a ginger
god
oh man uh
we're talking about diners what the hell
uh
oh we were talking about dinosaurs
earlier right yeah yeah me and sally
went to one you know last week yeah wins
it was good very good
i got it's right over here i think it's
on the 38th oh we should all go with you
guys yeah
i got the the beef barley we got a what
do you call a potato pancake
and the pastrami what didn't you text me
that you you said like you felt bad that
you knocked jewish diners or something
no we were knocking the garbage plate
yes oh yeah and then we went out and
ordered the garbage plate we just
ordered eight different things and ate
them separately but it was basically a
garbage plate on eight plates but that
feels a little more dignified it was
better it's like getting drunk on wine
versus getting drunk on like sangria um
you know
you're still drinking wine
but it just something feels a little i
don't know it's a little shittier
because there's sugar in there and
plants yeah when you dump it all in
together it's just a lot uh yeah i agree
i don't get sangria i think that's like
a a mom thing like moms are out you know
it's friday night you know the kids are
at summer school or whatever for me it's
like it's like a kid drink because the
hangover is just vicious vicious i had
friends in college who would make that
[ __ ] with like franzia
and they'd make it so it would taste
good but then like that next day or like
even as a kid you're like jesus christ
because what are you throwing in there
like you know uh tequila some people
have
people do weird [ __ ] with that like look
it up there's gotta be there was hard
liquor in sangria really not always but
you didn't know that yeah i'd never get
it never liked it no it's not like i'm
going to walk into a bar and be like
what kind of sangria do you have that's
not my go-to but i'm saying there's a
time and a place and i noticed every bar
says like sangria half off because
they're trying to get rid of that [ __ ]
it sucks they just make a concoction
what the hell is in that stuff
yeah look at uh which one just a regular
sangria yeah yeah yeah cocktail recipe i
know people throw weird [ __ ] in there
yeah i think they're just a lot of fruit
the fruit the fruit it's a summery drink
sure we need the bare
two tablespoons of sugar
more sugar
bottle of red wine
brandy that's what it is yeah but people
do different i think they do like uh
what's the thing that goes in a long
island iced tea everything everything i
know but it starts with a tea i'm
[ __ ] tequila no
tonic
interesting little fact sangria in
espanol means blood
nice good drink for a gay vampire
dracula damn it ah [ __ ]
blood wow that is not what the
difference between dracula and a vampire
is just dracula's a vampire he's just a
vampire that he's the famous vampire
yeah yeah is there an unfamous vampire
is there like ralph infamous maybe maybe
but all you know is dracula it's a whole
species of just one guy wasn't the whole
thing in the books he had the
uh the hair in his hands and that many
jacked off a lot yeah really yeah you
did this right as i said that was good
oh yeah i never heard that dracula's got
hairy hands because he wanks a lot i
don't what does one ever do with the
other i don't know i weigh it a lot i
think it just rubbed i think it was like
supposed to be symbolism or something i
have no idea look it up i've heard you
go blind i've heard that one yeah never
heard about the hairy hand mark where
are you uh no
wait what oh i was trying to yes and you
i just got it sorry
man you ever see blind people in new
york you're like wow you're like on the
hardest blind level yeah you're in
manhattan blind are you [ __ ] nuts you
gotta get on a train you gotta watch out
for city bikes you get this homeless
it's that's insane there's a lot
why did dracula have hairy palms
evidence of dracula's embodiment of the
victorian homosexual male and
masturbator and found in two separate
passages dracula is a victorian
masturbator fascinating
and he's gay hey dracula yeah wow a lot
of you talk to gay comics and they they
all will mention every villain in in
disney and all that is gay
it's weird you see a lot of them they
were a lot of effeminate yes yes because
and they'd be like the big brawny you
know tough good guy then the villain
would be like well talk to me batman
exactly you know it's always like that
yeah he-man was the only time where the
hero was super gay i mean who's gayer
than he-man robin's pretty good robin's
up there who i think came out as bi he's
bi yeah what did why why buy
what what cause they have to ease people
into it
i guess like he [ __ ] me [ __ ] women too
slow down
yeah yeah try explaining queer
it's like i don't even know queer means
you [ __ ] trans as well i'm looking it up
look it up i don't think that's true
that's what i heard from gay dracula
i i don't know queer i think it's also
it [ __ ] men women and trans
oh god
they're going to say folks men women and
children i'm like wow that's a that's
pretty progressive there yeah yeah
that's open-minded
i mean to be clear
boy your google history is getting wacky
today
i can't wait for your wife to have to
borrow your computer matt why are you
asking all these questions about gay
vampires
[Laughter]
i can't believe you shaved dude what
brought about what i haven't seen you
clean shaven in so long yeah i don't
know uh what what did it mean you were
sick of grooming the mustache or what i
just it was just ready for a change and
boom that was the change
it works it's really cool that men can
do that yeah women can't just i guess
bangs or like a ponytail or something
but like but change your whole face
change your face
my phone didn't recognize me i tried to
whoa
you know what's crazy about the facial
recognition it works when i have
sunglasses on
isn't that weird i'm like don't you need
my eyeballs but i guess not maybe it's
like just shape i think it's shape yeah
it's interesting you know what you look
like right now you look like you're in
like a fugitive type movie and you're
like on the low
and you just you change something
drastic it doesn't look it looks like
matt hiding not matt right yeah
something's up you're in uh witness
protection
when is protection
at a certain point at a certain age it
sounds fun oh yeah you know because
you're like you know i guess it depends
on your life but at a certain point
you're like man it'd be [ __ ] fun to
start over
new friends i could try a different
personality yeah you go there's too much
out there of me now that's true you go
live in boca you're a new guy yeah you
get to start a whole new life and and
choose it how many witness protection
people i wonder what the protection or
the percentages that go to florida oh do
they get to choose the state 80 let's
make it somewhere warm it's always warm
is it always warm there's got to be some
good fellas he's like oh just talk to
the guy tell them somewhere warm
i wonder do they get input on that
i don't think they want to give away the
uh the where the witnesses are that
would be too easy
well he's got to be out there i don't
know maybe i bet florida and arizona are
big ones i bet they're number one one
and two although if you were hiding for
your life you can't go to those places
when you go when you go like somewhere
like nebraska or somewhere
further off the grid that's a movie the
mob guy the new york mob guy goes to
nebraska and everything's slow and he's
like i can't get a [ __ ] slice around
here maybe this time he gets busted
because he's on tinder
maybe that's how they get him i used to
whack people and i whacked them up
my palms are hairy no i'm now i'm a gay
dracula look at me
man the mob i mean they have the height
of pinnacle of life they're getting
women and booze and money and all this
and then they always fall
it can't last
yeah it's weird like i was just reading
an article about this mobster who uh his
son he tweeted a picture of the dad in
florida and it gave away his location so
he got he went to prison
and then it mentioned like the crime
family and everyone the crime family was
like in the 80s and you're kind of like
how scary is that dude exactly to make
it that long right each year you survive
as a gangster is like another 10 street
cred oh yeah cause like your own people
want to kill you the other gang wants to
kill you the fbi wants to kill you the
cops want to kill you
it's not easy i was just listening to
sam harris on my way here
and uh someone asked him a question
about uh a guy was arrested in germany
for
uh crimes against humanity against the
jews he's 100 years old wow they're like
is it important to prosecute this guy or
is he no longer a threat to society hmm
he's not a threat but you got to pay for
your uh sins there pups yeah god bad
people live for so long 100 years 100
years old wow wouldn't you like to just
kick him once as a jewish guy like i
know he's old but he's like all right
that's the punishment is like you got to
put him in one of those like old school
friend show whatever
yeah oh yeah and everyone walks by and
goes
and that way he just dies of covid
that's that's how you get him
he's like juice bit it's burning
it would be funny if it burned that
would be great but ellie wisell is dead
this guy's [ __ ] a hundred that's a
good point it's a good point
maybe torching people is good for you
i mean i don't know i'm just trying to
figure out why they live so long it's
got anti-aging properties in it some
doctors like look i don't like bringing
this info in here but salmon and uh just
beating the [ __ ] out of people is really
good for your skin i know it's got
antibodies bad people you think about
that if you're like a dad who walks out
on your family you've got to be like
aging well it's less responsibility less
stress exactly if you're a deadbeat
you're probably doing all right
definitely that's why they leave going
out for a pack of smokes sure why do we
call them deadbeats we should call them
live beats
[Music]
all right mark it i'll tell you count it
you're all right
what a crowd what a knight what a
[ __ ] artist all right
you got to watch this dangerfield clip
of him on uh he's doing a set for ronald
reagan and george uh bush senior yeah
pull it up dude the amount of jokes he
rattles off wow you pull it up can we
plug this in the amount of jokes he
rattles off in like three minutes is the
crate it's like 400 jokes is it the
correspondence thing
i don't know it's not a correspondent
thing i don't think or the inauguration
i don't know what it is but it's like
nope
because there's another clip of rickles
at the correspondence reagan yeah and he
is killing
and it's like the worst setup ever for a
comedian and he and he pulls it out this
is one we could tell here we go
oh i've seen this you've seen this this
is great yeah just put on the first the
beginning because
or cut to a couple like 40 seconds in
when he gets momentum
reagan was pretty funny i gotta say
he's already funny
[Laughter]
that's already two
[Laughter]
told me it wasn't her fault she blew the
horn
yeah i know
he's waiting for that applause
had we all missed that joke
what do you think i feel she kissed a
dog on her lips and she won't drink
[Laughter]
these are clean
yeah
[Applause]
what a combo
[Laughter]
because it's like he doesn't even give
him a second that's like that's like
tyson in his prime
yes yes
just rattling rattling right it's like a
speed bag look up the rickles one that
would be great though inauguration that
would be great if you just went filthy
and there all of a sudden he's a
godzilla yeah i can't get a pair of tits
these ears
got a hooker in my room the other night
she wouldn't [ __ ] me like what the hell
she did
and the show
he just got serious he's like but
seriously my wife is cheating on me
i'm very unhappy i'll tell you they're
still laughing
pegged me all wrong i'm still bleeding
uh that's not the inauguration it's the
uh oh maybe it is maybe it it's a round
stage it's the it's like a hell gig
but he pulls it out it's so impressive
it's one of the hardest things
he was begging
second inauguration i don't think it's a
roast maybe maybe i don't know [ __ ] this
sure looks like it's it is that is that
brown
maybe that is it i think it's it if it's
not we'll go there oh yeah yeah this is
it emmanuel lewis
this kid's probably 41 right here
he had that disease
he picks on everybody equally
even a little kid like me
oh
i got nothing
i thought that was gonna get a laugh see
how hard it is pipsqueak
all right now rickles this he's just
[ __ ] blood right now i guarantee
like oh [ __ ] this is a tough gig
no opener no host
warm them up
this kid was the opener be funny
oh
now what now what are you no this is off
the cuff
yeah but he's already funny too i know
he's great both from queens by the way
the first black kid i ever saw he'll
definitely never play basketball
wow
come
[Music]
doesn't know on time it is and brings me
out you're standing here with the band
with the same kakamemi music
trying to learn that the president's
here is a big shot for me last night we
had bush well
i'll tell you this
he was great did you see him and his
wife after the show he was in the lobby
going nobody knows me
i gave him a cookie he went away he
didn't know what time it was
i'll be with you in a minute
i'll tell you this
just see some of his movies stiffs i'll
tell you this
this is a horrible gig i became
president when he was governor i
couldn't get in touch with him i had a
cousin did three months three months in
a county jail
he's talking to me
this is positive this is how hard comedy
he's going all off the cuff there's a
there's a million people in there the
president's in there and he's trying his
hardest to be funny so he's talking to
the the producer well this is the hard
thing when you do what rickles did which
is really off the cuff i mean sure he
had lines but like this is like
this is crazy it's an anxiety attack
you're like is he gonna come up with
something i feel for the guy oh you've
done you did that mtv gig oh
biggest bomb in my life five thousand
people that's not true i bombed in
wichita in front of schumer and 20 000
people but uh yeah that was the bomb of
the year
it's so tough it's tough you do a hell
gig sometimes and there's just there is
no chance no you just know you usually
you know but there is that ego that we
all have or like
no one's done well but i can turn it
around yep and then you go up there and
you're like oh i can't no no humbling
moment yeah and we're writers this guy i
mean he obviously has jokes in his back
pocket but he's such a [ __ ]
beast that he's like i'll figure it out
i'll figure it out up there i'll make it
work i'll talk to this guy i'll [ __ ]
with the kid that is so impressive to
just go no net like that well it's
insane yeah i mean that is known no net
and he's he gets it i mean in like two
minutes he's getting huge applause and
he pulls it out people don't realize how
hard that is fast forward a little where
he's killing
like the rodney thing he has the joe
he's got a rapid fire which is way safer
and also great but but like he had to
write those nuts i mean the the pace he
went not stumbling at all amazing just i
mean he must have run the hell out of
that also rodney and the bow tie it all
just works yes the whole entity is funny
it's not just the words
jay leno said there's two kinds of
comics this is a comic who says funny
things and the comic who says things
funny rodney is both yeah and that's
rare uh
[Applause]
you can see he's got his confidence back
go over to the embassy have a bucket of
beluga
anyway
anyway
and billy graham nice to see you sir
this hand is bothering
me ah
that's great
he's rolling
could have been a pitcher if i've talked
to this guy
it's great though i make fun of the
president why not i make fun of
everybody in the world that's america
laughing charlton heston i'm a friend
it's over
if you were moses i was a mouth fighter
pilot
[Applause]
it's horrible it's over
elizabeth taylor was backstage in a
cleopatra outfit killing snakes
i'll tell you this
was under the shower going look at this
the water runs up
i'll tell you this
this is too fast
ronnie i should call the president
ronnie he makes fun of me what does it
say
oh it's only a joke mrs reagan
[Laughter]
it works because
because reagan's laughing too though
yeah if you get a guy who's a bad sport
like if you had trump in that room he's
not trump at his own i mean do you ever
see the clip of artie lang talking about
roasting trump and uh i think he's
turning on seth meyers and he's he says
like you know uh
trump you know he comes into howard
stern they're talking and and trump is
like this guy had the the set of the
knives the funniest guy in the show and
then arty retells one of the jokes about
i think the joke was something about
like you know
uh
i forgot it was some joke about ivan
ivanka and the second he retells it
trump goes he bombed he just bombed he
had nothing what a dick so it's like he
couldn't take like once he remembered
that he mocked him right right you know
he he he lied and said he bombed yeah
that's [ __ ] up that's such a kid move
you're like an eight-year-old yeah man
yeah this is a we don't have to pull it
up because there's a lot of clips but
there's a trump video where uh i can't
remember who is roasting him at the
correspondence dinner but he is
stone-faced it's obama
is it obama yeah and people say that
this is the moment where trump decided
to run for president
you know what's weird 2011 was this
around when he was pulling the birth or
thing you know what's interesting too is
like um
there was a time where like
this was
fair game like we were not this divided
back then no you said something like
this it was much more now if you just
went up there and like playfully roasted
someone on either side the other side
would just call you like a cuck yes
they'd say you're like you know a
sellout you're part of the system great
back then it was like an honor yeah but
now with twitter you would just be torn
to shreds you're right like michelle
wolf tore apart both sides but people
knew she skewed left so she was torn
apart by fox news
you know they were like they were like
she's the anime right you know even
though she really did go after both
sides she did yeah she made fun of uh
what's her face his eye makeup
huckabee's huckabee yeah so you remember
the uh norm when he roasted saggett yes
and it was sort of like all those 1940s
jokes from anti-comedy anti-comedy um so
i heard sag talking about that after he
passed and he said the reason they did
that was because he respected me and
loved me so much he was like i don't
want to say bad things about my friend
right right so he was like and he can't
get up here and not say bad things yeah
so he went the other way yeah jokes from
the 1940s he also said in the room it
died he's like everybody you know
high-fived me after they said that was
my favorite thing and he's like it
bombed hard in the room which i believe
i mean he's saying like you got a head
like a flower cauliflower and the
audience is like what the [ __ ] going
on you know but it was legendary what
are you doing i mean comics are like oh
you're we know comics know how funny he
is so they know he's burning a hole yeah
but
yeah audience is like one time
it's weird it's like it is we all had
those friends early on when you're doing
like late night sets and you just decide
i remember joe mackie and i was like
early on we were at the comic strip late
one night and this guy glenn coyle who
like passed away a few years ago really
funny guy
he would do that he would literally just
stick around and try to make us laugh
like when the crowd was horrible one
night he just went on and
it was mother's day and he goes
i'd love to tell jokes but my mom
just recently passed away and he fake
cried for five minutes on stage we were
howling in the back the crowd was like
what the [ __ ] is going on but like he
did that for us and norm did that for
the comments right right that's [ __ ]
wild some comics just have that in them
where they're like i'm doing this for
you guys
you don't care that's what it is you
care so little which is weird because
of how desperate we all are yes it
really
we're all so desperate for laughs like
you can see it in mark and my comedy is
like we need to laugh pretty quickly
right a lot of we do a lot of punch
lines
uh
and there's some people who go up there
and they're like i'll get it when i get
it i don't give a [ __ ] and that it's
rare that great comics have that so when
great comics have that
you're like holy yes it's even more fun
to watch because you're blown away
that's a great point yeah
so true we're just trying to survive up
there and they're like i'll be good
yeah i don't have that
yeah i'm more like rotting where i'm
like
just because i'm i'm insecure
you definitely have rodney influence oh
yeah it's interesting i mean
i definitely i'll do story sometimes but
it is very painful for me to
to work to like write them to like
figure them out oh sure like matt you
watched me bomb a lot on roofs like
trying to like that's painful man like
it's oh yeah it's that doesn't feel good
no but i'm i'm glad it doesn't feel good
cause i don't want everybody doing it
but you're a funny storyteller when
you're not on stage
is there a difference for you like
trying to sell that same story to a
crowd sure i mean with you if i'm
telling you a story you like me so you
want the story to succeed i could be
telling this to you know a room full of
strangers who were like what wait you
like him
enough to for a story right but uh
you know stories are tough don't you
have a guy who comes up and goes i got a
great story for you and you go ah it's
because it's not also you just built it
up that too that's the kiss of death
oh maybe
i got something i got to tell you i got
a great story i got a hilarious one for
you oh
okay well now you just raised the bar
yep yep i like i like this how i like to
do it if i'm on stage and i got a new
bit even though i think it's pretty good
i'll go hey can i try one out here and
they're just like oh it's gonna suck and
then if it's good they're like holy [ __ ]
it sucks or like he told us it would
suck right
yeah i gotta move like that too i go uh
this this is where i'll lose half you
but [ __ ] it we're at a strip mall in
albany and that always hits just because
i'm in albany they're like we are in
albany you know they go nuts when you
mention where they are for some reason i
do it during sex i go this might be
terrible but let me try some [ __ ] out
yeah well what do you got on a peeve
peeve okay i got one this is an old
school one for me it bothered me me and
vito were doing it all week i used to
know a guy who would always go uh hey
buddy ugh
that buddy it just
it's tough
it's a tough one no i don't like it i'm
gonna go ahead and say the word buddy
all together
why don't you call buddy with sincerity
buddy's tough even when i texted like
thanks buddy i'm like eh it feels weird
bud is a little better
buddy you're going two syllables
it's kind of kitty it's a little
childlike it's like saying he's he's my
best friend you're like alright what do
you ate come on
little buddies even worse oh a little
buddy that's great for vitor though
he is a little buddy he's my little
buddy
hey buddy yeah buddy just the way he
said i was like oh so we do we just do
that voice all weekend oh yeah buddy and
it does sound like amigo he's he's
[ __ ] with you hey buddy give me your
you know your lunch money
let's swap some insurance buddy oh are
we friends yeah it's like when a foreign
guy goes my friend my friend you're like
we've never met
stop telling me your friend
yeah if you have to say it is it true
yeah exactly
yeah i've we've seen those i've seen the
drunk guy you definitely see the the you
know in those corner stores and the
drunk guy and he goes please my friend
you're like that's that guy's trying to
fight you right right you're trying to
trick him with a friend thing yeah my
friend my brother buddy yeah it's all
too it's too much of a leap pal yeah we
don't even know each other man dude or
kind of the safe one i don't mind man
and dude yeah i don't mind those bro is
fine i'm fine with bro seinfeld says
dude which is weird because he's like so
older he's so much older than us it's
weird that he's like what's up dude whoa
you are a child oh my god yeah that's
crazy i know in the wild he texts it
like oh that dude's great i'm like whoa
what are you a surfer oh my god i know
he's a kid what are we gonna talk like
when we're old probably the same exact
way queef and gay dracula and pegging
i know you know the movie comedian
backwards and forwards oh yeah remember
that scene where um he's on the beach in
like uh yes as a wetsuit and he's
hugging the wife and then she slaps his
ass yeah yeah he's like jumping for a
joy he's a kid we're all kids
you know i
i was listening that sounds like one of
michael jackson's defense
we're
we're all kids on the inside and i was
inside of him
sorry i was listening to the director's
commentary on that scene because i was
like this is so strange because it's
unlike every other scene it's also
the only scene that's like not in a
nightclub right uh and you see the
camera started going pulling away
and they interviewed the camera guy and
he said i felt embarrassed
to see something so intimate
and he sort of like just starts panning
away yeah that is it is weird seeing
that yeah but hey
he he [ __ ] edited it so it's it's
it's real too it's like true it's not a
movie
right that's gonna be weird like doing a
sex scene in a movie even if it's
tasteful you're like well i'm still
naked in a bed with a stranger i don't
know people watching i couldn't do it
with you for a second you had some
pretty revealing intimate moments in
your documentary that came out did i
speak that's true yes i did yeah
it's rare
yeah you know yeah most people aren't uh
filming themselves
most people if they're posting stuff
that's intimate it's like under their
control right on like instagram you were
filming me so it wasn't really like my
yeah i didn't really have control the
comments reflected that i don't know if
you read a lot of them they did yeah did
they
well we we rarely get sincere and
vulnerable so when it happens it pops
you know yeah well that's how it should
be it means more totally until you don't
know because some comics waste those
moments and they use them they overuse
them and then it guys this i guys i i
had to share i had to share this with
exactly i just booked an audition and
you're like
all right let me gather everyone around
let's take you out to dinner you booked
an audition i know act like i really
killed tonight it meant the world we act
like you've been there you really killed
tonight you're a comedian you're
supposed to be killing me some nights
are the type i have to share with the
world ah jeez blow me
get out of here the sex scene though i
couldn't do i had to make out with a
girl once in a like a college movie
whatever your film student thing yeah
and she pulled me in by my tie and she
was like the the what do you call it the
boss and i was the employee the intern
and she was flirting with me and i had i
was rock hard i couldn't i couldn't
believe it she was so hot and she was
such a great actor that she was like
come here big boy and i was like
i totally blew the scene and my pants
i don't know how people do it
i mean we did like four takes and
they're like you gotta get it together i
was like all right i can't she was so
hot you have to get it through the
[ __ ] what the hell
i was such a i'm a horrible actor and i
couldn't that's a great excuse you rock
are you jizz in your pants like i'm
sorry i'm not a good actor
sorry i'm covered in jews here yeah
uh doesn't work with the with the lady
i'm like sorry i'm a bad actor
finished in two seconds bad actor yeah
but i mean this girl was she was so good
at and i was like i was like 19 you know
i was i was a mess
damn yes so i still think about that we
didn't even touch we really thought you
were the horny age too yeah yeah and she
was probably like 25 so i thought she
was like a woman ah the whole thing
there's a great scene on an entourage
when johnny drama books apart playing
the brother of brook shields and he
talks about how he always had a crush on
her and he has a hugging scene with her
and he gets hard
[Laughter]
and she's furious but i got to imagine
like if that if you're on a if you're on
a sex scene like that must happen of
course maybe you probably yeah you
probably have to
jack off before yeah i know a couple
guys that's got to be weird do the coin
you just said give me a minute
i'm in the trailer the trailer's shaking
take five
[Laughter]
why are your palms hairy
all right gay dracula take one
but actors are always telling you we
know a couple actors they all go to film
our actor classes and acting classes and
they all say like if you want to hook up
with a girl you do a kissing scene with
her and then you're in like they go home
later and they win a practice and it's
over yeah
yeah yeah i remember i did an acting
class once and that happened ah there
you go yeah the whole scene was like i
was like a loser who was like trying to
hook up with her and it wasn't working i
think the like the last line was like
look do you want to get out of here or
not
and that was and everyone was like god
this guy's pathetic but then we ended up
like you know i think we're at a bar and
i was like look do you want to get out
of here or not right
you know but it's pretty hot
you know the girl's like that wasn't
great passion enough we have to do it
again and you're like
you know you purposely failed the first
time exactly exactly
but
man that that one gal ceo whoo
yeah see you later the one that got away
yeah i still think about her
we're friends on facebook i like
everything she does we might be drunk is
brought to you by my bookie football's
back baby oh my giants man i can't wait
you're a saints guy hell yeah who dat
you like easy money thanks to my bookie
and their lock of the season if either
the team scores in the nfl season opener
you win if you don't know how a game has
ended 0-0 since world war ii so this is
a sure bet head to mybookie.ag
select lock of the season and if any
team scores between the dallas cowboys
and the tampa bay bucks you win
the best bet you can make is one you
can't lose my bookie is also hosting
several exclusive contests including
their 100 000 super contest the best
part it only cost 10 bucks to enter
there's big money on the line this
season so don't wait to get in the game
join now mark tell them how to do it
hell yeah i just made a couple clams on
that jake paul fight thank you my bookie
oh yeah
oh yeah
and nobody believed in me
head to my bookie.ag today and use our
promo code drunk and instantly double
your first deposit that's double your
funds to double your winnings again
that's promo code drunk
to receive double your first deposit and
get started with my bookie today bet
anything anytime anywhere with my
book we might be drunk is brought to you
by lucy nicotine gum oh man smoking uh
it's hard to quit i used to smoke a pack
of day when i was in seventh grade and
i'll tell you lucy founded by caltech
scientists former smokers who wanted to
help people quit they said i was to
create a better cleaner nicotine
alternative three years of research and
experimenting and we made lucy a
nicotine gum that actually tastes good
you can get in wintergreen cinnamon
pomegranate wow i mean [ __ ] pomegranates
that's pretty [ __ ] good right oh yeah
high end each has four milligrams of
nicotine don't like gum check out their
cherry ice lozenge yes fight a cold
while fighting this [ __ ]
when you're craving a smoke you just
need a little something to satisfy the
habit so get lucy so you're prepared to
subscribe to a monthly delivery so
you'll always be ready mark tell them
how to do it you got that right they're
supporting this show so go support them
get 20 off all products including gum or
lozenges at lucy.co with code drunk and
who doesn't like a cigarette with some
booze so you're definitely going to need
this that's 20 off lucy.co
and use promo code drunk at checkout and
here's the part the lawyers make us say
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical no duh
get 20 off at lucy l-u-c-y dot c-o with
promo code
drunk
get on it today
oh let me give you a peeve hit me
now this is a little esoteric but
then the green room couple weeks ago and
i wrote it down immediately
the guy who's trying to be a part of it
too much so this woman comes in i got an
opener he brings like a his wife and a
friend and
i'm like trying to be nice i'm like oh
we're in the green room so uh what's fun
to do around here and she's like oh you
got to go to this amusement park and the
guy the other guy is sitting there going
oh it's on uh nicholson in columbus i'll
take you there and you're like all right
dude i'm just trying to chat with her
but he keeps chiming in with information
he's nervous he's nervous and he wants
to be a part of it and i'm like okay i
don't need the address man like i have
google i'll find it but the guy who just
keeps
trying to get in i remember uh i'm not
gonna say who one time we were at the
cellar and a big famous comic was
talking and we were we were nobodies and
we're sitting there and he's going uh uh
what's the name of that movie and this
guy the guy we know is going forrest
gump satan bright ryan ghostbusters and
we're like shut up let him just think of
it but he wanted to he wanted the other
guy to go that's it thank you and like
you know bring him in
and he was doing it also we're all so
desperate for approval man oh it's
killing me i'm like i'm just trying to
small talk with this lady i'll never see
again
now i got to appease you and go oh thank
you oh yeah yeah so now it's back to him
so it was just driving me crazy all
night yeah i know it's tough because
it's like clearly he just has social
anxiety right he's like which i get
probably nervous he's got her in there
right
she's
maybe he's maybe she's inappropriate you
know you know you have the con because
the girlfriend who gets drunk sometimes
yes and they're just like cramped
right she pours out his [ __ ] doesn't
work and you're like oh jesus
dwight's trying to cut her off all the
time yeah and i i you know i want to be
nice and i want to bring everybody in
but it was just getting it was getting
real annoying yeah
so that was my pee the guy who has to
keep chiming just because he wants you
to go thank you that's it we got it i i
thought you were going another way with
this i thought you're gonna say cause we
all know there's people back on facebook
who used to do the thing like uh you
know party party tonight who's coming
like that [ __ ] like they're inviting
people in that status
we'll be like i want to see this new
movie who wants to go with me and i'm
like you're opening the floor to anyone
that's insane i try to write a bit about
that that is insane yeah because you got
5 000 friends on here you are you're
okay with any of them going to this oh
my god throw a few texts out there what
do you think
even worse when they do that and no one
responds and you're like
you just died on your like what the hell
wow
talk about lonely man that's gotta hurt
yeah yeah yeah i mean we have a thing
where you know i guess it's comics we're
like we can hang out with about eight
people
that we like and that's it oh it gets
tough the bigger the group the worse the
hang you know definitely at a certain
point like once you have four or five
that's fine but then bigger than that
it's it's tough it's tough you're right
yeah is that is that us or is that just
a fact i think the the the quality of
the hang be becomes watered down because
like you spend we spend time we all know
each other well it's kind of easier but
then the more people to come you're like
kind of you're almost like dumbing down
the hang oh yeah to include more people
yeah
that's why i kind of like just doing
two-person shows on the road because
it's just me and like a really close
friend yes and not a stranger even if
they're cool it's like well it's still a
different hang yeah i've said it before
but the guy who asked for the guest set
he's like what i can't do five minutes
i'm like no it's the fact you're gonna
be in the green room for five hours now
i gotta hang out with you it's not just
five minutes on st if you did five
minutes on stage and and went home and
killed yourself that would be great but
then there's those comics that go the
other way and they just steer clear the
green room and you're like well you can
come in i'm like well that's true i
prefer that guy yeah i like the guy
who's like they don't want me in there i
like that guy
that makes me like you more
because you're worried about it at least
the other guy was like so cocky was like
of course they want me in there that guy
i'm like well we're already doing
push-ups in there
shadow boxing exactly too much he's
doing like somersaults and karate moves
you're like [ __ ] this is oh yeah eight
by ten room right here uh yeah man
that's uh
that's tough that's my wreck for this
weekend speaking of uh push-ups and and
somersaults what's that every morning
we're getting older salakis you're 68
you're 35.
you got a horrible neck yeah stretch
stretch first thing you do
in bed this is a healthy episode you're
recommending stretching we're doing
that's right
in bed you don't have to get out of bed
yet
when you wake up the sun is shining you
go like this
can you see that peters
you point the toes towards the face just
to get the legs stretched then you get
out of bed that's my wreck
interesting and then i do 20 of these
touch the toes while standing i'm not
trying to get full jack lalaine on you
but i'm just saying
it it helps
it gets the blood flowing
that's it that's good stretching's a
good wreck we don't do it enough and you
realize like at a certain point your
body gets stiff and
uh sometimes on a movie set
and
you get tight yeah you get uh i'm with
you man i i i need i need to stretch
more every now and then just touch those
toes and it goes a long way
you stretch
no this guy isn't stretching you you
used to play baseball yeah when i played
sports i stretched but not since i know
my girl can like touch her head up to
the ceiling i mean her foot up to the
ceiling and do a full split and i if i
tried to do a split i would tear
something but if we did it every day we
could do a split eventually
yeah probably but i'm i'm a long way
away it's hard when you don't see the
the goal anywhere yes anywhere soon
you're just like [ __ ] it's like when you
have a ton of [ __ ] to do in one day and
you're like i'm gonna do nothing yes
that's so true you know that's kind of
how i feel about it but you're right i
gotta i gotta get into stretching it's a
it's funny that that's your wreck
because i have a very kind of
uh self-helpy wreck my okay okay help me
classical music
it is good for anxiety
you throw some [ __ ] chopin chopin
whatever yeah you throw some of that
it's the mozart effect they call it
right you throw some you throw some
classical music on it it reduces anxiety
it alleviates your stress you walk
around it's good to do while you're
doing other stuff yeah also i can still
think of jokes while i'm doing that yes
yes it's instrumental it's not there's
no lyrics yeah and it still holds up and
then i made they wrote this [ __ ] in 16
whatever and it's still great yeah
unbelievable and also it's funny to
think that that was like the bieber of
its day
it was hip
isn't that wild
mozart was hip now you see he's got the
weird powdery wig and the tights and
everything but he was like a elvis
yeah crazy it's like drake put on that
new mozart but mozart was like a musical
genius genius and bieber's just kind of
like i mean also like our appetite is
trash not like oh yeah like he started
this incredible movement you know
musically and now this is where it goes
i know because
cd [ __ ] start running
music and seeing what sells and goodness
necessarily doesn't sell you know yeah
and also i think mozart was like the it
was for the elite you know it's like the
rich people came out and saw it sure and
like
yeah
it was the intellectuals and now the
bieber's for the uh the dumb like t
tweens well teens decide what's yeah
what's sales and what's good and no one
has worse taste than teenagers you got
that right they're like they're like
well you have to gear this for the
people with the worst taste yep so if
you're a great musician with depth who's
talking about real [ __ ] people are like
what no no but if you're if you're just
talking about like i have crushed and a
they're like this is [ __ ] gold yes
the same [ __ ] we've heard every year for
the last 40 years right book it you know
who wasn't playing at classical was
epstein
he had to play to his market
he was playing that ariana grande
[ __ ] yeah he's so fine i'm gonna
make him mine it's the worst [ __ ] on
earth it's [ __ ] bad they buy [ __ ] we
don't
yeah we buy we buy booze coffee and and
diner food and you know what if they put
one of her songs in a booze ad i'm still
buying the boost that's true because
then you can drown that [ __ ] out yeah
with the with the whiskey alcohol is
great now that we're not drinking i kind
of want something i would love to put a
splash in this
whole bar right now that angel's envy is
calling my name yeah oh yeah
angel's envy was good ah
that was like the one week we said we
weren't going to drink and we drank
because
we had a little shot i mean we said a
shot those mojitos were [ __ ] dynamite
too
wait what else what else do we do wreck
beef bit bit
i think i had another wreck hold on give
me another oh i got another rack oh i
got one i don't know if this applies to
you
i think maybe you and me and matt wash
your hair less
why why why would this apply to me
well you got such a brillo pad that i
feel like you don't you don't need to
wash it like matt that's he's got flowy
straight hair it's flowy dude yeah it
looks good you're like richard spencer
in his prawn
i'm gonna punch before [ __ ] went on bad
times for that guy yeah he did have a
great head of hair that nazi yeah
a lot of nazis had good hair you got it
you i mean you can't say the superior
race without having some good that's a
good point it's a good point you can't
be uh airy and pure if you've got a real
real horseshoe up there yeah
um but yeah wash your hair less i think
the hair's got a lot of uh good stuff in
it and we're washing it out
that's all i'm saying
less washing less hair washing i try to
do it less i uh it's tough i you're just
in there and you're like i'm so used to
this i know and it feels good you get
that tingle
i love a tangle i always say the head
you ever go to a salon and they do the
head wash
oh my god they get in there like this is
like
that's better than a happy ending
it is so sexual and the fingers oh and
that tingle and the water is just the
right temp and you kind of black out for
a minute and that ginger hits you and
that uh eucalyptus
oh i want to die that way
you know what really hurt haircuts for
me is the movie uh eastern promises
viggo that first scene where the guy
just gets his throat slit right just
opens with a guy in the chair and he's
like oh pull it up
i mean obviously if you haven't seen
that one's bad you haven't seen that
johnny depp uh
sweeney todd that whole movie oh yeah
but that one's so like
it's like over the show over the top
right right
musical yeah yeah but though we all
every time that barber puts that razor
in we all think it like i don't think he
could kill me he could totally kill me
i've had my ear nicked a few times by
that thing yeah yeah oh there it is
oh yeah
anyone else hard
that's crazy that they can put that on
youtube but you can't put like nipples
like a woman's chest but you can just
isn't that crazy that's hilarious
tits are two that's too private but then
you have a guy
yeah
i mean
this is sadder than this this throat
slit
yeah don't look at that the norm look at
this all right all right what do you got
what do you got on a bit here
i got one i can't crack hit me
it's kind of a two-parter it just
doesn't do well enough i know it's
missing something matt's probably heard
me try it all right so first part it's
like a two-part trans thing where i say
uh the first part does well this part
hits where i say you know i uh i was
talking to a guy and he goes trans
people i totally support it uh you know
i'll play along and i was like i don't
think that's what they're going for i
don't think they're you know
i don't think they're like oh cool he
called me a woman and then winked at me
that was nice
um but
so that hits but then the next part that
doesn't really hit is um like i get what
it's like being born in the wrong body
uh as a man with this voice
you know like as a man with his i see
guys who are shredded i'm like that's
who i really am right right that's how i
identify you know i see a guy with a lot
of plates i'm like that's me you know
then i have a whole thing about like i
respect what gender you are i tell you
why where i draw the line it's guys who
um i met a guy in florida and he goes
call me captain steve and i was like are
you a real captain and he said well not
technically and i was like well i'm not
i'll give you gender you don't get to
skip a rank that's my right right you
know what i mean like that so that's
that gets kind of a laugh but it needs
more and then and then i kind of this is
the angle i've been working which isn't
enough where i say
there was no struggle that you went
through to become a captain you just go
like at least changing genders that's
like that's a tough thing to do yeah was
transitioning's tough whereas just
saying you're a captain did like there's
no seven-year-old who's like dad sit
down um i'm not really a boy i'm
actually the leader of a fleet and he's
like get the [ __ ] out of my house that
just doesn't really hit yeah well
there's something there there is
something there i think captain you can
take steps to get there and it's all
mapped out for you there's no trans map
you can't go like i'm going to trans
class you know like you can't earn it
you know or you got hormone therapy
though right that's something i guess
but
it's gonna be hard and it's it's very
wishy-washy like i don't know if it's
gonna work out people are mad at me no
one's ever like there's a pilot get him
you know or a captain you know like a
captain can still go to the south and
run and you know walk into a restaurant
people walk up to you and shake your
hands if you're a catholic right
no no no trans person is giving me
little little uh wings or something well
my point is you've made your life harder
if you're trans whereas right whereas if
you're just saying you're a captain
you're trying to just like get credit
for [ __ ] you didn't do
yeah like a stolen valor stolen val or
something like that
yeah yeah yeah
it may be too it may not have a
a through line yeah maybe not yeah i
think there's something there with the
captain thing because you have to go
lieutenant
sergeant then captain or whatever yeah
there's a chain of command
yes exactly there's you don't work your
way up you just but then it sounds like
i'm defending the captain
well i'm just saying there's a clear
path with a captain trans is like
i was struggling i was confused no one's
like am i a captain
you know what i mean
no one's like i'm really a captain
inside yeah exactly exactly yeah the
captain is you work your way up no one's
like all right i'll go buy and then i'll
be queer you know and you get these pins
and then you make it to trans i made it
you also have another job
what do you mean no one's like a side
captain i was like this guy met like
worked in a bar uh-huh and he goes i'm a
captain i was like you're a bartender
you're like i know you let me see i can
say give me your tax return
yeah that's true you're not a captain
i'm trying to avoid the term cockpit
but yeah are we doing piloting captain
that's where i'm confused what could be
either oh it could be either okay i mean
you call a pilot you're captain don't
you this is yours yeah
all right just checking i'm thinking
military that's why but is that even a
captain well captain of a boat that's
what i thought you meant yeah that's
what i was saying florida oh captain
abode okay all right
yeah
yeah there's no bisexuals aren't like oh
here comes a trans person like there's
no rank
you know
bi is or trans just who you are you got
to become you got to change into who you
are yeah captain is not really it's not
your identity right
you still go home to your family and do
whatever and you clock out you don't
clock out of trance
that's something
you're trans all the time
also trans can still drink
pilot can't drink
you're stuck on pilot oh sorry
pilot is funnier to me because
you're flying a plane
boat could be funny i don't know i feel
like we gotta hammer down the the job
the job yeah i think it's boat and and
it's also like one of those things where
um
i like the thing that you could punch
out you can you can punch out of that
you're not
yeah telling your wife
saying you're a captain doesn't change
your relationship to people but anyone
who owns a boat can claim captain ship
or whatever you know he probably owns a
just oh yeah a cruiser boat and he's
like i'm a captain now you can be
captain steve i got it
whether you're getting a boat or a new
gender you got to name it
it's always a woman's name you know it's
always like uh you know seaward or
something
yeah
if i was gonna have a boat that would be
the name
um i've been sitting on that
the ore
uh
yeah either way
you're if you're a captain you're
getting a new you're trans you're
getting a new name yes
and
and your friends are like some of your
friends are like i accept you the other
ones are like i'm not calling you that
yeah and somebody i knew you before you
were captain exactly and they won't get
on board all right i love you all the
elements are here of this joke oh yeah
it's not formal no it's like you have
great ingredients and just doesn't work
no i know it's like well we need to find
the point what is the point you're
making that's right i think the point is
that
the thing you said about you're not
allowed to skip a rank yeah you you've
skipped a rank
with trans it's like boom boom but with
uh
i don't think it is boom boom i think i
mean the bruce jenner doc he's just like
whole life he's like i felt weird
something was off the transitioning
though yes that's procedure
oh the procedure i got you i got you
okay never mind
you can't get surgery and become a pilot
or a boat captain sorry
but i think what sam's point i think the
point joke is there's no struggle for
captain steve to do this if you're an
actual captain there's a struggle but if
you're just saying you're a captain
right
it's like me saying i'm a basket it's
like okay you're captain steve i'm right
reverend doctor sam morell uh
comma point guard for the [ __ ] knicks
you know
there's no there's no uh consequences
you just want you just want a cooler
name
yeah
cut your dick off and i'll call you
captain how about that but you uh
why well because yeah i mean that's
transitioning right the procedure i know
it's a bad term um
i could have used flowery or language
but you get my point
all right hey you wanna get in these
waters you gotta no no no i i respect
the swings you're taking man
the joke is clearly not good enough yet
so it i think the point is that it is
tougher
to be trans and to just say you're
[ __ ] a captain right right you didn't
even do the work like trans people it's
almost like if a trans person
just showed up as a guy
like dressed like me with a five o'clock
shadow was like yeah i'm a woman and
you're like well you gotta do something
yeah you can't just show up and be like
like if matt like if matt showed up with
his mustache today and goes i'm now uh
matonya
and i was like well you know i would
respect it but i'd say could you could
you get rid of the mustache could you
put a little effort in my fridge right
could you like i'll play along but you
got to play along
i just said what i hate yeah
wow
yeah well that's that's not a good sign
if you're saying
no but i'm turning another guy my point
is like
we both have a part in this aha
you gotta do your part do your part
you gotta earn the medal and you gotta
you gotta earn captain you gotta earn
trans that's my goal that's the point i
like it okay crack that this weekend
i'll figure that out yeah that's at
least the angle i don't know it yet but
yeah you gotta yeah like what did you do
make an effort
go to go to [ __ ] h m and buy a dress
or two you're right
or else we could just do this all day
i'm a woman i'm a man a woman i'm a man
like you gotta you're just gonna be
correcting people all the time i i
respect that you were transitioning but
like put in a little work and and then
we're all like yes you're a woman yes
that's all i'm saying he's getting
little fox newsy uh is it is it
you're saying you got to have a uniform
yeah all right if you're going like if
you're going if you're going through
this chain for you to tell me what my
transition is supposed to look like oh
see that's where
where it gets dicey
i i'm a woman and i want my mustache the
[ __ ] are you but you can't expect me to
know that you're a woman
this is a little fox snoozy okay
uh we're just trying to talk it out no
we i mean that's the problem i i see
this good that we're having yes yes it's
getting hot in
where's here shot
yeah
all right well y'all know you're right
that's not it yet that's not it i'm
because i'm i think i'm taking the wrong
angle here
i'm taking an angle i don't necessarily
believe in
yeah well that's not gonna work and then
if i do believe in it too much then it's
not it's more of a point and it's not
funny enough so so maybe i have to shelf
this one for a while wait what was the
original thing that got a laugh in the
way beginning of the bit the thing was
he goes i'll play along which is what i
just said which is hilarious
and it's like
that's not what they're going for you
got to kind of accept it you're not
playing along it's not a play it's their
life that's the joke i think there's
more there yeah yeah yeah like it's not
an eight-year-old with a fireman cap on
and going oh you saved us you you put
the fire out no this is a lifestyle it's
an identity yeah you know that's the
joke uh-huh sticking with that i'll be
back all right sorry for that long
[ __ ] detour i feel like a captain the
long [ __ ] trip i took us uh where we
went nowhere we hit an iceberg i think
it's a real beauty in what you guys are
talking about here yeah because you know
the foil of your joke is this jerk who's
like i'll play along but the truth is
that's me too
of course it's coming from your brain
well that's why i think it gets a laugh
is because like we i we identify with
that person yeah we also identify with
the trans person we identify with both
sides right and it's it's both sides of
your joke brain working against or with
each other but that's human
and i think that's a beautiful thing
that you guys can do publicly and like
talk these things out it's like
conversation you hope yeah there's
people who just want to shut it down but
it's better to talk the discussion is
going away i do want to be called
reverend doctor from now on if that's
okay
point guard for the new year
all right i like to be called margaret
i got two ideas they're both
[ __ ] so they're not worse than mine so i
just i luckily just ate a fat one for
you to cruise right in well i still the
play along is is there's a lot there
that's the funny part so far we'll
figure that out yeah there's no program
you know you're not like oh we're not
playing along you know it's uh it's who
i am
all right so uh
two ideas one i'll just just [ __ ] on it
and i'll get rid of it but my friend is
scared of flying and we flew together
recently and he was freaking out the
whole time and he's like i'm scared of
flying but oh good news i got an exit
row and i'm like oh wow i'm jealous
because you got a better seat than me
but isn't it weird that you're so scared
of flying yet you chose the seat where
in case of an emergency you would have
to save us
is that anything isn't it weirder the
exit row is like
oh yeah you know we had our headphones
in we're reading a magazine they're like
if anything happens can you we're like
yeah yeah yeah yeah move it along skank
i got to read this you know but like
if something went down you would have to
save us and we're all just so
nonchalant about it that's how bad
flying is
what do you mean you'll do crazy things
for an extra couple inches aha yeah
that's how uncomfortable it is but it
also shows how safe it is oh yeah
that'll never happen i'll be fine
that's insane i think what he was saying
was i'm the first one out
no i don't think so i like the exit rose
because i know that i can open that
[ __ ] door not to rely on joe blow oh
i'll be the first one out if something
goes wrong
all right all right i don't know is
there is it [ __ ] i'll get rid of it i
have another one didn't get a laugh in
the room here well it's not it's not
even
it's an idea it wasn't even a i thought
there could be something to it
it is a little cat it's so casual that
we're seeing that we
we're that nonchalant about saving the
entire plane like it's all on us well it
just goes to show how much we trust
these airlines yeah you could never do
that if that was like a roller coaster
you'd never be like if anything goes
wrong
you're our guy yeah you're the hero you
don't even have all your teeth i don't
[ __ ] trust you right right with the
rat tail yeah yeah all right it's
nothing but it i thought it was
interesting how it
we just
yeah yeah yeah i got it let me listen to
my podcast you know but you're in charge
of saving us
something there maybe who knows i like
how they the stewardess or the flight
attendant comes up to you and he or she
is like i need a yes from you if you're
in the exit row yeah yes from you like
that's all you need is it yes oh that's
interesting yeah look at my body type i
can't handle this [ __ ] well that's a
heavy door yeah yeah
uh yeah that's that's true all i need is
a yes
all right how about this
me and my girl are fighting i got too
many girlfriend jokes but we're fighting
and
i feel like i was winning
but then she pulled a haymaker and i
realized
couple fights
need a
judge need a judge and jury they need a
like a a ref like a ufc match
you know like sure
i might have won by decision but she she
did knock me out
you know like i had more points but she
got the knockout in at the end so she
won she won
like you need a guy
like in the ufc when they go when they
get when the person's getting hit too
much who just like pulls them off yeah
yeah
you need you need that guy but in a
couple's fight exactly yeah
because
and then sometimes she'll fight and
she'll just be like ah [ __ ] this and
slam the door and run to the other room
and i'm like
but i won that
you know i need somebody to call it yeah
but the point is that you guys make up
the point isn't that there's a winner
that's the funny part to me is that like
like a guy running in and raising your
arm doesn't do [ __ ] in the long run
that's a good cause you got to go back
to like that's like if
like
you know if the fighters had to hang out
afterwards
right that's funny you know that's funny
yeah
yeah they had to go back to their tiny
studio apartment together
yeah and [ __ ] one of them's got a black
eye and crying the other one's like i'm
sorry
you made me do this
yeah
it would just be nice if there was a
judge because sometimes it's like you
said she can start crying and i'm like
but i'm still right just because you're
sad i still
i still won this thing
i need to win by decision but but
winning is resolving it's not that's the
thing
a win is resolving the thing it's not
it's not being like i best you you're
not proving you're wrong that's the
problem that's like what a lot of people
you're like well i [ __ ] won but
you're alone right away right
yeah so maybe it's the opposite of a ufc
fight
or a boxing match because when you win a
boxing match you get all the glory you
get the [ __ ]
rose necklace and the champagne and all
that
but when you win an argument you're
alone you're alone that's it i mean it's
interesting and you know
a couple therapists aren't trying to be
like well mark wins
they have to be like well here's what
you both need to work on right
right i think maybe it's a guy thing i
think as a guy i'm like logically i i'm
right i won this but she's still crying
and hates me
and both end in a rear naked choke
yeah i have a bit similar to that
actually
already all right well i guess see the
problem is we recorded two in a week and
we'd have a lot of time to uh
[Music]
you know we got to come up with these
bits out of thin air yeah so it's hard
when you well but i think there's
something there something there not
wanting to win and wanting to resolve is
the win yeah that that's but but it's
tough because it's like there's no
preparation for like fighting and then
being like well here's what you did
wrong and here's what i did wrong
there's no preparation
right there's no other fights you have
as a kid like that nothing nothing
that's why relationship fights are so
weird because you're like but i
i had a good point and you're not giving
me the love when you get into a fight
with a bully in school you're never like
that indian sunburn you gave me was
great here's where i can be a better uh
fightmate yes yes yes
i should have been wedgied longer you're
right yeah
next time i'll keep my head in the
toilet
for more time and you can flush again i
was tapping out okay i never listen all
right jesus yeah yeah
that that's something
that this is the first time
you're fighting like this because
remember how weird it was when you were
in high school and you had your first
girlfriend or whatever you're like
she's mad at me i don't know what i did
this is weird and your friend's like i
know i know
i think there's something here okay all
right well
fighting with the girlfriend of such
relatable stuff i know
yeah i got this uh bit about how women
are like the opposite of cars except
the check engine light
because you're like i know something's
wrong but i don't know what the hell it
is and that that's doing pretty well
yeah but that's that's different that's
all another thing what did i do yeah
right literally always
a woman has never asked me that
a woman's like i see you've been down
for a couple days what is it
i don't want to talk about it
i've never been if something's wrong i
will [ __ ] tell you of course
it's obvious you stepped on my toe you
you burned my
favorite
record i don't know it's all it's all
things your record
i'm 78 years old
you burned my vcr you threw in my
winston reds what the hell
who are you oh god you got my velvet
coat too i tell you
but yeah
yeah we're we're pretty uh surface level
we're pretty cut and dry here we're dumb
ah i don't know
we [ __ ] around look at steve jobs
i'll tell you bill gates
pretty smart
warren buffett
elon musk just donated 50 million to a
red cross oh not enough it's not that
much money when you
isn't that crazy that he does and you're
like that's nothing that's gotta suck to
be a billionaire i know that's what i'm
saying like you're worth billions and
you get like here's 50 million you're
like
okay
i know thanks not not really a drop in
the bucket for you elon he's like all
right next time i'll give nothing you
chooch what do you want for me a lot of
money oh yeah more money than we'll ever
see you got to lie about your wealth you
got a lot when you're like it was like
half of my wealth right there that would
be like holy [ __ ] he's incredible yeah
yep
can't win you damned if you do
he won
i think he win
i think he won yeah i guess you're right
got a full head of fake hair you like it
i love it it's it's not real hair oh
come on i don't know nobody's there i
don't know much about him well check out
an old elon and then check out a new
elon and it is night and day wow look at
that is that real yep
i mean good for him if you got the money
it's like getting fake tits for a guy
it's a drop in the bucket there you go
50 mil on that bucket list
yeah look at that he's got uh all that
hair i mean no one's gonna listen to the
guy on the left
i got an idea for an electric car get
out of here
you don't even have hair
bald man has no ideas right
we don't realize but we judge people by
the how they look quite a bit or animals
look at that that guy the guy with the
hair that guy is on to something
i feel bad now about my take being so
fox newsy because it's like i'm working
out these bits and i'm like yeah that's
not me it's working out a bit though
okay
it's a trans bit too so we have to go
to the line you know what's in danger of
doing this in a podcast you know yeah
but they get it they get it and when
selkies caught it
well that's why it's good that you're
here because mark is never gonna catch
something like
that mark's never going to be like i
think you went a little too far with
that one no let's go far
let's go for it buddy
i love that mark's reaction was was it
i still think it was fine we're
discussing now we got to figure [ __ ] out
you got to figure it out trying to
figure out my life
people that i offended saying this is
going fox news because they're like
exactly snoozy exactly
yeah they
i think there's something wrong with
msnbc too i think i think if you sure if
you're going too hard on either of them
it's it's a problem but yeah
we're just trying to be real right down
the middle cnn baby
i don't know about that
how about uh local news we're going
local here all we talk about is uh
murder and kidnapping yeah and the
weather
squirrel on skis
local news is fun i love local news now
that now that i never get booked on
those local news shows i
i actually you miss them
because they're kind of
they're kind of fun it's kind of fun to
cause a ruckus on those it is yeah
those poor people are just in a
in a local news cage they can't say
anything real they can't say anything
interesting they can't curse they can't
be honest it's gotta be a horrible way
to live we're the exact opposite of them
they're all bob saget from full house
yes
how are you oh
oh this is delicious
cookies later we have a special chef
coming in we're going to make cupcakes i
tell you oh the dog groomer's here oh
the dog in the head i'm going to murder
my wife oh look at this little dog
i'm going to slit her throat and i'm
going to get away with it too because i
have all this pent up rage yeah and then
they bring us in and it's four in the
morning and they're like be funny you're
like you ever had to put peanut butter
on your balls and have a dog lick it
they're like
[Applause]
jesus christ i murdered my wife and i
don't speak like this
yeah
what kind of comic are you i'm a
comedian what do you want it's seven in
the morning yeah those are tough when
you just they you literally just down
like two cups of coffee uh in ten
minutes your throat's on fire
wake up you go on they're just like so
how'd you get into comedy and you're
like
i was diddled what do you want me to say
my scout leader went to town middle was
clean needle is clean
yeah those hands were clean
but uh
well it's an ad for purell right there
kills 99 of uh germs and 40 of guilt yes
all right there it is folks
i do i should say another thing i have
to call myself out for some [ __ ]
here uh-oh
i have to call myself out peeve on
myself
a couple months ago when i said i got
back into therapy i said it was my idea
it was not my idea oh
uh i was court-ordered and no it was my
girlfriend was like you need therapy and
i was like yeah i do and i went it was
her idea i found i feel like a phony i
don't want to lie on him all right i
lied i told a lie i'll play along
[Laughter]
i don't like telling lies on the pot all
right i'll tell you well we appreciate
that i'll be in uh
indianapolis
there you go
indianapolis springfield missouri
chicago
denver
phoenix
sf
it's all october november uh new york
theater show get on that [ __ ] might
probably sold out by now hopefully we
got a [ __ ] uh
uh we got
yeah san fran buffalo cisco uh buffalo
dallas
and what oh man let me know how that
goes i don't i don't remember agreeing
to that one
that's in richmond baby i didn't do that
really
you're going to add a lot to the jew
quota in that town i'll tell you that
geez i'll go up 100 yeah that one
get off me look at my emails real quick
yeah am i coming to richmond we'll see
ah i heard it's a decent room but
they're new they're definitely new all
right what do you got on me here yeah
there you go who the hell is dead frog
what does that mean
i don't know do the dates line up is
this accurate uh sure
i'm in uh
nashville i'm going off i'm going off
the top of my dome here because i don't
know who you got stephen wright's dates
up here
give me my website i have a website i
pay a lady uh
um what the mark going there it is
all right scroll up your queef what are
you doing here we gotta get a new guy on
the uh keep going there we go boy who's
this written for an ant
all right we got comedy on state mass
wisconsin this weekend zany's in
nashville rochester
garbage plate helium portland laugh
boston brea improv in california good
looking website mark oh thank you thank
you pale lady vancouver british columbia
new orleans howling wolf comedy castle
in michigan wolf classic first place
ever got paid due comedy buckhead
theater in atlanta the dark comedy
festival in toronto
funny bone and syracuse i didn't say yes
to that either call my agent will you i
just i just confirmed in january i am
doing that gig i just went through my
email oh there you go i will be at the
sandman club
sam man get him out of here
so uh yeah see us on the road email us
uh for the patreon we might be drunk pod
at gmail.com wrecks peeves suggestions
drinks drinks yeah
whatever you want uh
yeah look at that looks good margaret oh
thank you thank you it's about 10 years
old now i got a bunch of photos up there
patreon.com we might be drunk pod leave
us a nice review
uh i'm sorry my bit was whatever this is
stronger yes yes we need a week to come
up with some [ __ ] this is my shrine to
the
semites
larry david the king
all right thanks folks we'll see ya keep
listening we'll see you soon
comedy
[Music]
you